religion gives people purpose it gives  people good values when you remove the  religion what is there where does your  Hope come from when life is tough you  don't have anyone to pray to you don't  have anything to ground you that's where  I think the victim mentality and the  wokeness started to come from because  it's like we need something to fulfill  our minds because times were so easy and  there was a lack of religion people's  brains started to wonder it's what we do  we have to create problems it's just how  the mind works if it's bored and I  literally think wokeness was born out of  boredom and entitlement and an easy time  the Leia Marathon show